was it like uh were you like rapping a
lot like were you like in terms of like
were there were there any ciphers going
on [ __ ] used to try to give me the
route but they knew you were a rapper
right yeah but I went with this [ __ ]
right yeah I'm here to do my time I'm
not here to entertain everybody no I'm
doing time man now don't get me wrong
it's been a couple times where
screaming a couple of good men
couple good man we getting the sale
smoking some joints and [ __ ] right he
was like we're gonna speed us one night
y'all two three on let y'all see how I'm
Gonna Come
and thank you for the [ __ ] the streets
up with that [ __ ] I stay out there man
oh [ __ ] like this so y'all I I have but
not just no free just in the units yo
you had talked about this a bit with uh
wallow about because I have two of my
big cousins who've been incarcerated
most of their life and anytime I talk to
them or when they would get out and I
would talk to them something you brought
up and something that they also brought
up they're locked up in Arizona so the
politics are a lot it's a lot of race
related [ __ ] you know but
um they would always tell me about these
riots like when the prison riots would
pop off [ __ ] would be crazy people dying
I heard you talk about you ain't even
got to be involved in it
that's what I'm saying like they would
because
she can pop out between some more
[ __ ] and that one [ __ ] that
that they never liked you and you don't
even not know that this is opportunity
to get you so because it's a
free-for-all Bingo but you ain't even in
it right but once you go up it go up and
then you got all the police running to
this area when that [ __ ] stole you up
on you with a knife or you know what I'm
saying like yeah it should get Wicked it
get Wicked like this [ __ ] it's a whole
different world dog no I already know is
it is it something like where you at
like was it ever a point in time during
a situation like that where you felt
like
you know it was close for you in terms
of
you know wrong time wrong place or
I mean you know what I'm saying uh by me
being affiliated with an organization
isn't that time where I felt like it was
over with when I was like you know I'm
saying get bump ahead with my
organization right you know what I'm
saying like you know because it feels
good if you get what I'm saying like
yeah physical sometimes like when you
break certain rules and [ __ ]
and I feel like God damn I might not
make it at this [ __ ] because I
know me you know what I'm saying like I
ain't good with authority
I'm not the police but guys in the
organization I ain't you know what I'm
saying so I always stayed in some
[ __ ] because I went good with with I
went good with
you know what I'm saying [ __ ]
tell me what to do
yeah and then also [ __ ] I mean
no matter where you're Affiliated at
least from what I heard once it becomes
prison everything changes in terms of
like structure or
the politics the rules everything just
it's a whole new game right no different
yeah